the universe is made of matter 98 of
this matter ignoring the dark matter is
pure hydrogen and helium
but thankfully billions of years ago
supergiant stars fused the hydrogen and
helium into all the other elements and
then exploded them all over the universe
and that's where chemistry came from
these elements group together into a
vast array of different molecules and
these molecules combined with each other
in a stupendous number of complicated
ways chemistry is the subject that
studies this matter in all of its forms
and how it all interacts it goes from
simple atoms right through to complex
biological molecules like proteins and
dna it's a huge fascinating and complex
subject and this video is all of that
condensed
humans have had an interest in chemistry
for a very long time we wouldn't be what
we are today if it was not for the
chemical reaction of fire we use this to
develop other chemical techniques from
cooking food making metal from ores or
making glass amongst many others since
then many advances in human civilization
have been built on the back of advances
in chemistry like metal working or
manufacturing fertilizer or making new
materials and drugs
let's look at what falls under the
umbrella of chemistry first there's mata
and all the different things that matter
is made of
at the very smallest scale we start with
atoms in the periodic table that
organizes all of the different types of
atom called chemical elements
elements in each column have similar
chemical properties
atoms are made of protons and neutrons
in the nucleus with electrons
surrounding them and most of chemistry
is due to how these electrons behave
by joining together atoms you get
molecules and different kind of molecule
are called chemical compounds
chemical compounds usually have very
different chemical properties to the
elements that they're made from think
about it hydrogen is very explodey
oxygen is very burny but combine them
together into h2o and you get water the
least explody burny thing around
compounds don't have to be made of
single molecules many solids like metals
or salts have a crystal structure made
of repeating groups of atoms called unit
cells if you have several substances
together you have a mixture like the air
around you or a cake
now let's move on to how atoms stick
together with a very important subject
of bonding
atoms bond together in several different
ways where they reduce their combined
energy by stealing or sharing electrons
or moving them into different
configurations a universal rule in
science is that everything is always
trying to minimize their energy and
bonding is one way that atoms achieve
that
understanding how energy moves around in
chemical substances is vital to
understand when reactions will or will
not happen for example word won't react
with oxygen to start burning
spontaneously but if you give it enough
energy to begin with it will
another example where energy is very
important is where you can speed up a
reaction between two other compounds by
introducing a catalyst and the catalysts
make it more energetically favorable and
so speeds up the reaction
energy also determines when compounds
will exist in the different forms solid
liquid or gas
which form they'll be found in comes
from the temperature that they're at and
the pressure that they're under
the values vary for each material but in
general things are solid at low
temperature and or high pressure and gas
at high temperature and low pressure
another really interesting form of
matter is a plasma which is where you
rip the electrons off atoms in a gas to
make them into ions this is what's used
to make neon lights
chemical reactions form the core of
chemistry which compounds react with
each other why they react and what is
left over after a reaction
there are many different kinds of
reaction which can be categorized in
different ways all of these reactions
are governed by a set of fundamental
rules called chemical laws the
foundation of which is the conservation
of mass and energy which means that no
matter or energy is created or destroyed
in a chemical reaction they just change
to different forms
kinetics is the study of how fast
reactions happen and the things that
control what the reaction rates are
a reaction where electrons are
transferred from one reactant to another
is called an oxidation reduction
reaction or a redox reaction for short
oxidation means a loss of electrons from
a substance and a reduction means the
gain of electrons and they have to
happen together an example is sodium and
chlorine chlorine is the reducing agent
and sodium is the oxidizing agent
another important property of substances
is their ph whether they're an acid or a
base
there are several theories to model
acid-base reactions but one way to think
about it is that acids are substances
that have a hydrogen ion ready to give
up in a chemical reaction and a base is
a substance that takes a hydrogen ion if
there are a number of different chemical
compounds which can react with each
other back and forth there can be swings
between one substance and another
equilibrium is where the amount of each
substance is constant even though a
reaction may still be taking place this
can also happen in phase changes like
from solid to liquid or liquid to gas
so those are the basics of chemistry
research in chemistry looks at how these
rules apply in different chemical
systems so now i'm going to move on to
look at the different fields in
chemistry
theoretical chemistry attempts to
explain the structures of atoms and
molecules and how they interact using
mathematical methods it's very closely
related to theoretical physics and
quantum chemistry and often uses
techniques in computational chemistry
where atoms molecules and reactions are
simulated in a computer now simulating
the proper quantum behavior of anything
more complicated than a single hydrogen
atom is very difficult impossible for
multiple bodies so many cutting-edge
techniques in computer science are used
to try and simulate molecules and how
they interact with each other
in fact this is one of the most exciting
applications of quantum computers
because they'll be able to directly
simulate chemical systems and help with
things like discovering novel materials
and drugs and a whole lot more
physical chemistry studies chemical
systems in terms of their physics so
things like energy force time motion
thermodynamics quantum properties
amongst others there are many subfields
like looking at the electronic
properties in electrochemistry which is
important for developing better
batteries or material science which is
trying to create materials with new
properties like extreme strength
durability or self-healing this is a
critical problem with building
earth-based nuclear fusion reactors
which are reliant on new materials
analytical chemistry is like detective
work you've got a sample of something
and you need to work out what it's made
of and the amount of the different
components chemists have developed a
huge array of techniques to probe and
measure different properties of
different materials traditional
techniques involve wet chemical
techniques like precipitation which
separates compounds depending on what
temperature they evaporate there's also
a huge array of modern techniques like
chromatography where different compounds
move at different speeds through a
solution and so separate for the many
different kinds of spectroscopy that can
detect materials by shining light on
them or mass spectroscopy where the
materials are flung through electrical
magnetic fields to separate them
according to their masses
and finally we get to the huge fields of
inorganic organic and biochemistry
organic and biochemistry look at the
chemistry of living things in inorganic
chemistry looks at everything else
although there is still a large amount
of crossover
most of the inorganic compounds that are
studied are man-made and a lot of the
motivation is to find chemicals with new
properties that can be used in the
chemical industry in the wider world in
fact there are very few areas of human
endeavor where inorganic chemistry has
not been used in some way
there's medicine and agriculture special
fluids like detergents or emulsifiers
special coatings
materials pigments or fuels for many
industrial purposes
within chemical production itself
catalysts are very important as they
speed up other chemical reactions
inorganic chemistry also bleeds into
material science making solids with
novel crystal structures like high
temperature superconductors for example
the list is is endless
now between inorganic and organic
chemistry sits organometallic chemistry
this looks at organic compounds which
are bonded with a metal and are
typically used in reactions in the
chemical industry often as catalysts
organic chemistry looks at the structure
and behavior of the molecules of life
which are typically built from a small
set of different atoms carbon hydrogen
oxygen and nitrogen plus a few others
organic chemists also look at making new
organic compounds with useful properties
organic molecules all contain carbon and
the carbon hydrogen bond is the most
common structure in organic chemistry
there are a huge number of applications
of organic chemistry in industry
fertilizers pesticides lubricants
polymers and plastics
and in the consumer world there's
fragrances flavorings and preservatives
and of course drugs in the
pharmaceutical industry
and finally out of organic chemistry
comes biochemistry which studies the
chemistry of living organisms
biochemistry studies components that can
be inorganic like water or minerals but
also looks at the biggest most complex
molecules like proteins fats and dna
at the other end this field also blends
into molecular biology which looks in
the finest detail at how life arises out
of the chemical processes inside cells
within biochemistry there are four main
classes of molecules called biomolecules
carbohydrates are used for structures
and storing energy lipids which make up
fats
proteins which are very large molecules
made from amino acids that have a huge
array of different functions in the body
and nucleic acids that are used to
convey genetic information
research in biochemistry has had a huge
impact on medicine helping us understand
infectious and genetic diseases
improving organ and tissue
transplantations working out what's
wrong with you with clinical diagnostics
and of course understanding nutrition
looking at the functions of vitamins and
minerals in our body biochemistry has
also been very important for agriculture
studying soils fertilizers and pest
controls and there's many other
applications too so that is my attempt
to summarize all the chemistry in about
12 minutes no simple task as it's so
incredibly complicated
it has always amazed me that something
so complex as a human is built on a
foundation of a huge number of simple
chemical reactions
your consciousness right now is a
function of the chemistry going on in
your brain cells oxygen being passed
from your blood and sugars being
metabolized inside them
chemistry spans a huge mountain of
complexity from a single atom to the
cells that keep you alive and i find it
endlessly fascinating
like with all my other videos there's a
poster available so if you want to get
hold of that check out the links in the
description below otherwise thanks again
for watching and for me it's back to the
drawing board